only seven hours left to prevent another
government shutdown the deadline is
midnight we're waiting an upcoming vote
on a spending bill by the Senate it's
expected to pass there but uncertain in
the House Democrats once again stalling
on the budget to force a fix over
dreamers Nancy Pelosi pulled a dramatic
stunt yesterday a record-setting eight
hour speech on the floor so now we have
the first republican president in modern
times the first president really who is
anti-immigrant we're not asking for
something offs of also wall it is
something that is yeah maybe it is off
the wall maybe the wall is the issue
here the Republican moral cowardice must
end during the night when I was thinking
and praying so hard about our dreamers I
thought maybe we should just pray all
day on the floor of Congress maybe I
should bring my rosary blessed by the
Pope did it yield any results even
Democrats aren't happy with the minority
leaders performance one of Nancy's
colleagues fell asleep during the speech
another unnamed a liberal tells Politico
quote this stunt had nothing to do with
protecting vulnerable members who have
to take a difficult vote
and here's congressman louise gutierrez
good for her I'm happy she's stepping up
I hope now she keeps the fight going
speeches are great they're good they're
important and I'm thankful for the
speech but more important is to maintain
your principal maintain your political
principles alright well this has been
said many times before Kimberly but I
think it's worth repeating Nancy Pelosi
has never stood up that long for
veterans for police officers for factory
workers for constitutional rights but
when it comes to illegals she's there
for eight hours
religious freedom work or anything yes
exactly
well you know but this just goes to show
you where her mindset is and it's it's
politics and ideology at all expense and
so then the problem is she comes off as
not being a very genuine person it comes
off as a sort of you know political
circus and theatrical and you lose
credibility when you do
things like this and so you know this
unfortunately she's had this reputation
for quite some time she represented my
district in San Francisco with my ex has
the number one Zant what can I say
interesting yeah Thanksgivings and
Christmases I can imagine yeah I feel
the same way back into that Republicans
love this
they say Nancy do eight do sixteen they
want to see more Pelosi it's a great
advertisement her face of the Democratic
Party I mean this is the gift that keeps
on giving
well you have to admit it was an
impressive physical performance she
outdid outlasted all the guys for the
20th 21st century and she did it in high
heels so it's like Ginger Rogers she did
the same thing as Fred Astaire only
dancing backwards in high heels
how do you know Rand Paul was not
wearing hahaha that's a story I've
always wanted to program but I for me to
couple the budgetary process with the
dreamers plight is a terrible miss
service a disservice to the dreamers to
the daca you know to make them the issue
this inflammatory issue immigration
raises the hackles of people on both
sides and to make that the headline for
the Democrats point of view on the
budgetary process is so unfair and so
counterproductive I just think that you
know I only wish that I was in charge of
this aspect getting the dreamers there
their future secure I think that Nancy
Pelosi did absolutely nothing to further
that goal and a lot of people in her
caucus believe that they say you know
you were at the bargaining table you
said this is a good bill and then you
were gonna vote against it what was the
point yes done but that is true although
I'm trying to put myself in maybe more
of a progressive or a dreamer shoe and
choose a high heels even and looking at
it from that perspective and Nancy
Pelosi has been under the gun for a lot
of different reasons of course she is
the public enemy number one for
Republicans and also there's this
intergenerational discussion going on
with the Democrats and suggestions that
at 77 years old she is needs to move on
and then she showed them that
actually I have more stamina than all of
y'all stand here for eight hours and I
will talk about the issue that the most
progressive part of our party cares
about so maybe it doesn't advance the
ball legislatively but perhaps for her
politically it does help her in the
midterms with that section of her base
pretty impressive
eight hours Tom have you ever done
anything for eight hours every day it's
all I do eight hours I'm here at Fox
News that's a record anyway I mean I saw
mr. Smith goes to Washington he was
there for like two days okay it's the
Senate and is that that's what Ted Cruz
- Ted Cruz did 21 hours and everybody
made fun of him eight is that impressive
care about the heels I mean these stunts
appear tomorrow not to talk actually
don't these stunts have not been working
they we've had the Schumer shut down the
Pelosi marathon speech they've been
boycotting the inauguration is there
something else besides stunts Kimberly
that the Democrats have no every day
it's like Ripley's Believe It or Not you
just what are they gonna do next I mean
what are they actually getting done how
about helping people and coming to the
table and working cooperatively and I
say this you know for both sides that
everybody needs to do it because the
other side is me guilty of the same so
we got to call it out right now we call
it out when we see it from the other
side but let's actually get some
traction here and try to do something
you're eight hours are better spent
sitting at the table with key members of
the other party or with the president
and actually trying to work on something
American people are tired of this dog
and pony show and you know the Pelosi
pony show in the heels not here I mean
come on it's like enough already about
Ted Cruz to I mean where the Democrats
said this is a stunt that will get you
nothing and it didn't get them anything
so elections are the best revenge the
only thing that you can do to get
pressed when you're in the minority is
to do a stunt that will help you and
remember they don't care that they're
not getting good press here they're
getting good press back in their
districts or on their blogs that's what
matters to them they've raised they're
raising more money than Republicans so
far I think that could change in q1 of
2018 after the tax reform bill is in and
Republicans numbers including the
presidents are way up compared to then
but for right now the best thing that
they could do is get enough press if
they can in their districts but raise a
ton of
and try to win the election that's the
only way that you actually win and
they're not raising a lot of money
they're in debt on the DNC side they
have a lot of bills to pay Geraldo the
media is not talking about the split
within the Democratic Party they love
the cover splits in the Republican side
but how deep of a split on the left is
there over this issue well the short
answer is I don't know that there is a
Democrat a democratic party anymore
but I just want to go back to what
Kimberly said how impressive how
surprisingly optimistic was that
yesterday we saw Mitch McConnell
agreeing with Chuck Schumer to go
forward on a two-year budget EULA two
years there's not going to be 10 minutes
not gonna be two days 2-year budget deal
here they were the majority leader the
Minority Leader standing one after the
other my colleague my colleague I said
my god that's the way it's supposed to
work and then today we're back to this
crap again I just think there's too many
before we move on I think they're gonna
get something done by even if they can
they go past midnight can they do a
little extension they always like to
bring it to the last minute okay the
clock back yeah 11:59 they'll get
something done I think